and finally new rule now that Americans
are finally returning to the office
after the pandemic let's let them [ __ ]
not necessarily right on the copy
machine but you know in general
bring this up because last week the
Boston Celtics became the latest
Corporation to show an executive the
door for what seems to be acknowledged
as a consensual relationship when they
suspended their head coach IMEI udoka
now for sure not all the facts about
this case are known and if it turns out
he was violent or physically coercive
then his case has nothing to do with
what I'm about to say and he should
expect the appropriate and severe
punishment but in general
it's long overdue that America had an
adult review of our war on office
Romance
you know there's only a few places where
Americans meet each other in person
anymore work bars church and Adam
Levine's house
[Applause]
now in the udoka case the widely
reported description of it has been
improper intimate and consensual
okay intimate and consensual I shouldn't
even be reading about it
what people do that is intimate and
consensual is not my business not yours
and that not that [ __ ] little
leprechaun
[Applause]
improper on the other hand probably
refers to a power imbalance between the
two parties and yes in a workplace
setting a power imbalance can be abused
it is a real thing to watch out for if
it involves coercion
or promoting someone who doesn't deserve
it because they're blowing you
[Applause]
but to deny two humans who are anxious
for each other the chance to find love
in the same office is a bit
anachronistic as most businesses now
have serious protocols in place where
employees can report and get relief from
being harassed this is no longer the Mad
Men Days where there was no HR no yearly
mandatory sexual harassment seminars and
the metoo movement hadn't happened times
have changed and yet nearly a quarter of
employers require all employee
relationships of any kind to be
disclosed really God forbid grown-ups
start making decisions about their own
bodies without getting corporate
involved
and when it comes to managers and
subordinates the majority of companies
don't allow any relationship at all
of and where it might happen
is like the last mystery
it's serendipity
also when you're [ __ ] someone at the
office you know they can hold down a job
[Applause]
[Music]
under current guidelines Michelle
Robinson could never have dated Barack
Obama
who was a summer associate at her Law
Firm when they met she was literally
[ __ ] The Intern
[Applause]
wasn't there a power imbalance when Joe
Scarborough started dating Mika
Brzezinski I'd have to say yes since the
name of the show was Morning Joe
not Morning Joe and Mika although now
that they're married I wouldn't be
surprised if that's next
laughs
in 2019 the CEO of McDonald's had to
step down therefore it was discovered
that he was having a consensual
relationship with an employee I know
gross who would date someone who works
at McDonald's
[Applause]
but I remember reading about the Scandal
and wondering where the Scandal was
there was no harassment no off-color
text no dick rubbing against underlings
I mean we all know that no doesn't mean
yes but now yes does it mean yes
what happened to my body my choice
same thing happened to the CEO of
Priceline forced out because he had a
relationship with an employee but come
on it's hard not to have an affair or
two when you're getting such a bargain
on hotel rooms
[Applause]
but this is how sex works now the rule
is if I want to have sex with another
willing adult but we both work for
Hyundai we need permission from Honda
somebody else
and we just accept that like taking our
shoes off at the airport
earlier this year Jeff Zucker was forced
to resign as president of CNN after he
admitted he kills hookers in a van
oh wait no that's not what happened
I'm sorry no he had concept he had
consensual sex with a 49 year old CNN
executive who didn't complain then and
doesn't now she said they were in a
relationship sure like a 49 year old
executive knows better than we do about
whether or not she's a victim
who are we protecting here exactly who
at CNN would have been traumatized by
this unauthorized boning the war
correspondence
this couple has been in the news a lot
lately why aren't we freaking out about
a director dating one of her cast
members
our imbalance are you kidding on a movie
set the director is God
but sometimes people fall in love with
God it's a very attractive position
who are we to tell other people they
can't have love because when they met
they weren't exactly co-equal
people are not always attracted to their
co-equal we're not robots what we are
apparently is lonely there is a
loneliness epidemic out there it is
widely reported a morning consult poll
found that almost four out of five young
adults consider themselves lonely and
have trouble forming relationships
outside of their home and that certainly
seems the case in the incest porn I
watch
foreign
[Applause]
if loneliness is destroying our health
causing depression anxiety low
self-esteem and shortened life
expectancy it's just not helpful to be
criminalizing the pool of eligible mates
that is the workplace does anyone really
think that swiping right on some Rando
because he has nice hair and he's posing
in front of a Dodge Challenger is a
better way to meet someone than at the
office
hahaha
and not for nothing when udoka was fired
they replaced him with a guy who was
once arrested on charges of domestic
battery but it's okay because they
didn't work together